triple a nevada expects most of us to
stay home for the holiday this year and
as expected christmas travel will be
down because of the virus
in fact the centers for disease control
wants us to stay home to help slow the
spread
hector mejia visited the las vegas strip
to see what some travelers had to say
about it
first i talked with aaa representatives
this morning and they're also warning
against non-essential travel and here at
the welcome to las vegas sign
people are still flocking this landmark
to get their pictures taken
you know most are getting around by car
aaa says
road trips are estimated to make up 96
percent of holiday travel this year
and according to aaa at least three
quarters of travelers are expected to
stay home this holiday season
that means 34 million fewer people
compared to 2019
and despite that drop though as many as
84.5
million americans are getting out anyway
between now and january 3rd
the cdc is urging people to just stay
home
we asked visitors how they feel about
that warning and what brought them out
here
at a time when many are choosing to stay
in for the holidays
this was kind of iffy as well but just
us together what i'd recommend is maybe
a small road trip you know maybe some of
the parks you could see or some of the
landmarks
you know we thought maybe the hoover dam
but i think we landed here
we are here just for visiting state
parks to avoid all the
kobe scenario 2020 also ends the 11th
year
of consecutive holiday travel growth it
was just last year when triple a
expected
more people than ever on record to rush
home for the year and celebrations and
in terms of next year
2021 we are told that the covid vaccine
is bringing some promise some hope for
the industry
reporting from the las vegas strip
hector mejia 8 news now